[Music]
hi
and welcome to a very special episode of
the google cloud platform podcast
i am mark mandel and i'm here with my
colleague melanie warwick hello melanie
how are you doing it's like our after
school special it is our after school
special yes
um you convinced me to do a mid-week
episode
i did there was some news that broke in
in the last couple weeks around the cpu
vulnerabilities
sometimes known as or known as meltdown
inspector
so we were able to get in touch with the
security guys on our end
had provided some great content around
blog posts that are out there and how
it's impacted gcp
so we got them on the podcast so that
they could talk about the blog and give
us some additional insight
and we're going to go ahead and jump
straight into that for everybody we're
going to skip our cool things of the
week we're going to skip the question at
the end because we are focused mostly on
making sure that we provide this
information
out for everybody to have access to
excellent let's go talk to matt and paul
all right on this week's podcast we have
some of our security experts joining us
we have matt linton who
is our chaos specialist we have paul
turner who is a software engineer
and we are going to talk about the cpu
vulnerabilities that were discussed in
the last couple weeks and
had some good content that has come out
around how to protect yourself so
before we dive into that a little bit
can you guys tell us a little more about
who you are and what you do
my name is paul and i work on the
operating system and kernel team here
i was involved from a fairly early point
in resolving this vulnerability trying
to find
mitigations ways to improve the problem
and how to do it in a way that really
had the minimal impact and my name's
matt i'm an incident manager on google's
security and privacy team
my team is the 24-hour escalation point
for suspected security issues
and other things that urgently need
security engineers attention
great thank you so i know you both
co-wrote a blog post that was helping to
outline how what these vulnerabilities
are but can you tell us a little bit
more about them
sure so essentially the the core of the
vulnerability is
something that's been latent in cpus for
a long time probably close to 20 years
and it exists in sort of an efficiency
trick that cpus have been pulling to get
faster and faster
what happens is when you make a request
of the cpu
and there's a couple of different
potential answers that may result
sometimes the cpu will start executing
all of the instructions
and preparing the results so that when
you ask it for the specific
answer you wanted it's already got that
answer ready to go and give you
instead of having to wait for you to
instruct it and it turns out that there
are ways that someone can take advantage
of this
by tricking the cpu into executing
branches against areas of memory that
would not ordinarily be accessible to
that person
and then retrieving the results from the
speculated they call it the speculated
branches
yeah i just wanted to add that i thought
the way that matt describes this as
tricking the cpu is a really good way to
think about it
generally speaking the cpu is trying to
do what it thinks should happen next in
your program
but these attacks have discovered new
ways of
tricking it into thinking that something
should happen which wouldn't normally
happen during correct execution
and the way that that occurs allows some
protection to means to be bypassed
so what are things that are vulnerable
to this type of attack well unlike a lot
of
um really dangerous attacks that we've
seen before and
sort of the good news first is that this
vulnerability is a read-only
vulnerability
the really core danger here is that
someone can trick the cpu
into giving you access to areas of
system memory
now that's very important because we
have a lot of secrets in system memory
that you want to keep secret you have
passwords and encryption keys and pretty
much
numbers credit card numbers any kind of
data that you would normally be
processing and care about
will touch memory but unlike previous
vulnerabilities such as heartbleed
an attacker can't just reach out touch
you and you're done right
there already has to be a way for the
attacker to get onto the system in order
to exploit this vulnerability to steal
secrets
now i don't want to minimize that
because this is the security industry
and
every good pen tester knows there are
hundreds of ways to get onto a system
um but it's not you know once and you're
dead like heartbleed was
well and i read that this is impacting
you know personal computers
mobile phones as well as cloud services
is that
accurate yes there's three kind of major
variants that were discovered of this
attack
each of them apply to various
sub-cases of how we use computers today
variant one is particularly important
relative to the encapsulation that we
use for things like javascript engines
variant 2 is particularly important with
respect to how we isolate
virtualized machines you can think of
cloud hosting and variant 3
is also really important in that it's
the most direct way on a consumer
device to steal somebody's data
uh if you are able to arrange for local
execution
so that's that's actually really
interesting because i've noticed as a
consumer
i've got um i've got information to like
patch stuff on my cloud provider as well
as like upgrade my browser and i think
i've seen stuff about like upgrading the
driver on my gpu
is that because there are just a variety
of ways of taking advantage of this
vulnerability
exactly when you see suggestions that
you should patch your operating system
many of those really are looking at the
third variant where you can attack local
system memory
whereas some of these other variants
that we see uh varian one and variant
two
commonly referred to in the media
inspector you're seeing they are seeing
providers uh applying the protections
you're seeing browsers adding
protections for variant one you're
seeing cloud providers adding
protections for variant one and two
like always in security protection means
fixing
everything and some of those things are
intended to be employed by consumers
and actually when you mention spectre i
wanted to ask you
you know we've we have heard of the
terms meltdown and spectre
but i also know the blog post that you
guys provided doesn't necessarily
mention those explicitly
matt you wanted to mention a little bit
about that yeah so
there's been a decent amount of
confusion out there over spectre and
meltdown and all of the variants
the background behind this is that there
was a little bit of a co-discovery going
on with this vulnerability
john horn from google's project zero
discovered the vulnerability and kind of
teased it out into
three distinct variants that we call
variant one two and three
a few months later another research team
who was also looking at the same
sort of way to trick cpus discovered the
vulnerabilities as well
and they chose to give them names naming
a vulnerability is something in the
security industry that is
kind of a little bit preferential right
if you like to name and logo your
vulnerabilities you'll do it and if you
find it to be uncouth you don't do it
so project zero did not choose to give
names to the vulnerabilities but the
other researchers did
and so they named them spectre for
variants one and two
and meltdown for variant three and the
reason we ended up with two names that
covers three vulnerabilities
is that the team that named spectre um
hadn't discovered
all of the things that make variants one
and two unique from one another
and so they thought that they had two
bugs but they really had three so we
ended up out here with this naming
confusion where spectre
covers variant one which is most
deployable
in jits and browsers and things variant
two
which is most exploitable as a
hypervisor bypass
and then the whole separate variant
three that they call meltdown which is
most exploitable in terms of interacting
with the operating its system itself
and the thing that's important to know
there is where matt said variant one and
two
apply to the browser and hypervisor
and then that variant three applies to
the host operating system
for all consumers out there the patches
for linux and windows are already being
included in those operating systems
so as long as they upgrade to use the
latest versions
they will be covered and that means
macbooks as well as those who use the
linux operating system
that's correct apple has also published
patches for this round really i should
have included in the previous list
no words so this is interesting too like
so you said that the vulnerability is at
like a cpu
level but a lot of these patches are
coming at what are essentially a
software level
how do these fixes kind of work then how
does that
help people the fundamental thing that
all of the fixers are trying to do
is arrange for the execution to be
occurring
in a way so that the tricks that are
being played
no longer apply in the case of meltdown
for example
you are tricking the cpu into looking up
memory
that it shouldn't normally be able to
access and the way that that was
mitigated
was by instead of using the regular
access protections on that memory
completely unmapping it in those
contexts
that it should not be accessed this
meant that
even if speculative execution were to
try to access it
it didn't actually know how so that's
where very one and two have similar kind
of approaches where we're trying to find
ways to restructure the program control
flow
so that these ways that you can
influence or bias
when the cpu is guessing what to do next
are constrained or eliminated
i think there's a good opportunity here
too to talk about
how the words fix and mitigate tend to
be used very intentionally by security
engineers to mean specific things that
other people might not really
put together when we say that a
vulnerability is fixed
we mean that the actual root
vulnerability is no longer present in
the device
a lot of the software mitigations that
you're seeing come out
these patches for windows and things
they're not fixing the vulnerability so
much as they're mitigating it by making
it impossible for someone to
take advantage of and the analogy that i
like to use for that is you know if you
have a broken window
you can fix the window by replacing the
window glass you can also put a board
over it to mitigate the hole in the
house
you haven't actually fixed the window
yet you've just made the hole in the
house
impossible for someone to come in
through so in terms of the fixes and the
mitigations
especially from a standpoint of the
actual processors
i know at ces the ceo of
intel brian krasnick had mentioned that
they have
basically patched or they have provided
a patch for 90
of the vulnerabilities affecting the
processes or they will be by the end of
the week
and that they are expecting to handle
their remaining 10 by the end of january
without
them requiring to recall any chips
did you guys hear about that did you
have any additional comments that you
wanted to make on that one
i would extend the analogy that matt
just made it's clear that for the
current generation of cpus
we will only be able to develop
mitigations and not fixes
so we're going to be driving with the
boards on the windows for a long time
we do expect that in future generations
that
these problems will be fixed at the
hardware level however we are also
optimistic
that for all current cpus the
mitigations can be deployed
so that we do not need to replace or
update the hardware
so what are some of the things we've
done for gcp and g suite and also
additional internal google products and
services that are provided
there we've deployed and in many cases
developed the mitigations that are being
used across the industry we have to talk
about them on a case-by-case basis
because there are three variants and
they each have their own mitigations or
fixes
however in all cases we have deployed
fixes and mitigations that we believe
cover
all known classes of the current
vulnerabilities
and ensure that customer data is remains
protected
yeah it's difficult to talk about this
succinctly in cloud especially
because this vulnerability affects so
many things and cloud
by nature affects people at different
levels right
you have software as a service where
somebody's buying the software
and access to it from us like uh drive
right docs
gmail we're providing everything from
the software on down
and it's very easy for us to easily just
say having mitigated our infrastructure
that runs those
products and having checked the software
for vulnerabilities we're confident
we've protected people there
but then there's things like gce which
is infrastructure as a service
people are paying us to run everything
from the hardware for them
and manage scalability and network and
all those things
but they also want to run their own
operating system inside a container
it's more complicated there because
we've protected
all of the things that they rely on us
to protect for them
but you can't simply say everything's
fixed because if a customer runs their
own operating system
and they're worried about attacks
occurring from within their os
to their own data stored in it they also
have a little bit of work to do patching
for these variants as well
a good example of this would be a
multi-tenant customer where you're kind
of
someone might be doing re-hosting where
they're using a you know they're
purchasing
hosting from a cloud provider such as
google or amazon or microsoft
and then they're internally kind of
releasing that space to their own users
they're the attacks that matt just
described in many ways they are
a hosting provider themselves and so the
infrastructure that they've contributed
that runs on top of the underlying
hosting providers
such as google microsoft amazon that
infrastructure must
also be protected and that's something
that they must do in their own
development and deployment
i want to go back a little bit uh we've
been talking about mitigation and fixes
and that's actually a really interesting
turn of phrase
and maybe to extend the metaphor you
know if if i have
if i have a boarded up window it's
nowhere near as pretty as
say a fixed window but it sort of works
kind of the same but maybe i don't have
as
nice a house if i have we have we're
talking about mitigations for this
vulnerability
are there any sort of side effects or
consequences of these mitigations
that may end up sort of in the wild that
may be necessary but
should be stuff that people should look
out for maybe that's a really good
question
obviously as you say a boarded up window
is not something that's going to add
value to property
so we've been very careful in how we
develop these mitigations
to try and make sure that the effects of
that were not observable
it's definitely true that in early
versions when we were kind of
prototyping and developing internally
we were seeing overhead from many of
these fixes or
mitigations but as we evolved and found
newer and better ways to add those
protections we
really were able to minimize the
overhead that we saw in many cases we
actually see no perceptible overheads
for both our own and customer workloads
while still providing
these protections yeah we boarded up the
window with clear plexiglas that's
mostly indistinguishable from the old
window
and in terms of gcp in regards to what
was being updated and
boarded up was there any maintenance
downtime there was not
you've described the guest and host
level mitigations that have been taking
place
what do you need to do in regards to
achieving those host level
mitigations being applied to your gcp
instances
so when you say host here what you're
really talking about is
uh the google level mitigations right
when we say host
we mean the infrastructure that's
running the virtual machines that we're
providing to our users
there we're actually very fortunate in
that we have a technology we call live
migration
which allows us to move a running guest
between host instances
without requiring a reboot or otherwise
interfering with the guest
we were able to actually use this to
transparently deploy all of our
variant 1 and variant 2 mitigations for
our infrastructure
with no customer reported downtime but
this does mean that people just i just
want to hit this point
people do need to upgrade their own
operating systems if they're managing
themselves on something like gce
or gke or something like that definitely
as a matter of best practice users
should be patching their own operating
system
the vendor i believe that's most
important there is variant three
also known as meltdown while that attack
will not allow
information to escape between the
hypervisor or our infrastructure and
their operating system
it is possible that local attacks from
within their vms on their own data may
succeed without those patches this is
really a this is really a matter of best
practice
something i keep hearing from people is
you know make sure you update your
software
whether it's os whether you're on a
phone whether you're on your
you know operating system on your laptop
you always want to make sure when you
see new patches come through to keep
updating them
do you guys have any additional
recommendations for best practices
around security
yeah i would say that anytime a complex
vulnerability gets discussed a lot of
people turn to wondering well what
should i do about it
and you know in security we kind of have
consistent messaging out that most of
the time
the answer is keep yourself updated with
software patches from the vendor
and make sure that you're using
two-factor authentication and
other protective layers on anything you
care deeply about
and the reason we always come back to
hammering on that is
most of the time those are the two most
effective things you can do to protect
yourself not just against this
vulnerability
but in general against vulnerabilities
that you know about
vulnerabilities that you don't know
about you know tomorrow's big discovery
that may come out
it's all going to end up boiling down to
take care of the things you're running
keep them updated and keep your
authentication safe it really does come
down to best practice
the guidelines that we're proposing here
are uniform within the security industry
with the idea as matt said that they
believe you in the best
position for unknown vulnerabilities
that you may not know about
and because often when a vulnerability
like this
is discovered you have to be able to
update your software quickly
and if you have not been keeping up to
date with other
patches or security improvements in the
infrastructure you could have a large
technical debt which you might have to
mitigate in a very quick fashion
when something like this comes out so
those those practices are both
preventative and in making sure that you
can be as agile as possible
in responding to these issues when they
arise so you're not saying that there
should be any
change in the way that people are
handling their security best practices
really it's it's
the tried and true methods stay the way
the same way they are
yes generally speaking uh variant three
or meltdown is not externally
exploitable
so users are only really vulnerable from
their own software because we've already
patched
our exposure to very one and two and
their exposure to variant 1 and 2 from
our infrastructure
but again we really do believe this is
the best practice we strongly encourage
all of our users to
apply these fixes just as they would any
other security effects
to ensure that as new ways to attack
both
this and other parts of the system are
discovered they can continue to be
protected as
quickly as possible can you guys comment
a little bit too on the fact i know in
the blog post and with what project zero
released they were saying how
this was identified and then there was
coordinated efforts to try to do
the fixing and the patching before it
was going to be announced publicly
would you be able to comment a little
bit more about that process and what
that looks like for coordination with
security
to an extent this is one of those things
that is really difficult and always gets
handled on a case-by-case basis
which is you have a giant bug you have a
lot of work you need to do to fix it
other people you know also have a lot of
work that need to happen to fix it
and then you end up with
interdependencies right if
google were to fix this bug all on our
own without contacting anyone else
then other operating system vendors like
apple and microsoft wouldn't be
protected
and our users would be left at risk so
for something of this scale
there's always decisions that need to be
made around what other companies
need to know they need to know to
protect the users
do they need to know so we can protect
our users
so we can protect ourselves and a sort
of an ad hoc
group ends up forming of people who are
affected who believe they have something
to contribute to fix
it and who are all sort of giving and
receiving
advice and technical data from one
another
to try to put all the users on the
internet in as good a footing as
possible
when we're ready to talk about the issue
without creating such a large group that
it becomes impossible to keep the issue
contained
and this really was an industry-wide
effort our own
attempts at mitigation uh began at the
same time as other industry players we
weren't trying to provide a head start
for ourselves or
any other advantage we really saw this
as an industry-wide problem that
everybody would have to try to
contribute both in terms of
finding ways to mitigate these
complicated
and difficult vulnerabilities and in
making sure that everyone would have the
chance to deploy
the protection before disclosure
occurred yeah there's a little bit of a
thing called
supply chain which plays into this a lot
too and supply chain
is a security industry term which
references the fact that
you inherit vulnerabilities from those
you trust to provide you with things
and so i'm speaking to you right now
from a macbook pro
right i have a supply chain dependency
on apple to make sure apple is secure
if i am to do my job and keep google
secure
so in a lot of ways these sort of
multi-industry partnerships
for something this size um are brought
about by necessity from the fact that
the supply chain forces us all to
adopt at least a little bit of each
other's problems
you uh you kind of said something
interesting that i don't know if people
who aren't necessarily familiar with
how security research sort of goes you
mentioned that up until the point i
think you said that it
it was going to be public or it was
going to be shown to the outside world
can you talk a little about how that
research process goes about finding
vulnerabilities and then finally
making them public and the steps that
sort of go through that and why those
steps exist
sure those steps exist as sort of a
compromise that has slowly developed
over time
in the it industry itself their
processes often these days called
coordinated disclosure
and what happens is a security
researcher finds a vulnerability
and they report it to whoever it is
that's actually
makes the product the vulnerability is
in and then the
vendor and the researcher agree upon a
period of time in which
the vendor gets a head start on fixing
it to actually protect people
before the researcher gets to publish it
that's in contrast
to a behavior called full disclosure
which is when researchers find a
vulnerability and immediately disclose
it to the world
there's a lot of pros and cons and i
don't think probably this is a good
place to go into it unless you have a
couple extra hours
but i can tell you what project zero
does is they have a standard process
where
they find a vulnerability they notify
the maintainer
in whose product the vulnerability
exists and they give them 90 days
to remediate it before project zero
discloses it
and if the vendor is able to remediate
it earlier then they disclosed it
earlier in coordination with the vendor
and that's sort of a compromise that has
been reached
between the pros and cons that hit you
when you go full disclosure
and the pros and cons they hit you when
you allow the vendor to completely
control
disclosure so much of the security
research industry right now lives in
that compromise zone of coordinated
disclosure with
a defined time period and this got
released a little earlier than expected
is that right
yeah but relative to what matt was
saying i think this is
the actual more interesting point there
is this was an example
of a issue that was so pervasive and
affected so many uses
that we actually extended that standard
90-day policy
because it was clear that all of the
supply chain level mitigation
that users would require would not be
possible to deploy within that window
so while it's true that ultimately
the disclosure happened a few days
before we had it originally intended
that's really almost after the fact
relative to the discussions of
um how that timeline was being managed
yeah so
part of the decision-making process here
in terms of
disclosure is there's a really difficult
and constantly evolving decision to be
made around
is keeping this issue on the down low
and giving people time to fix it
better for users and better for
individuals
than telling the world about it and in
the early stages of this and in a lot of
the mitigation phases where
everyone had to develop patches we had a
performance test patches we had to
validate that they worked
obviously keeping it on the down low and
giving people time to fix it
so that when the world learned about it
everyone would be prepared to defend
against it
was better for everyone but you know to
a certain point
people began to realize that there was a
lot of fixing going on without a lot of
talking about it and they began to put
two and two together
and really clever individuals very close
to the end of when we were
almost prepared to announce it anyway
some very clever people started putting
together
public examples of both the flaw
and how you might use it to attack user
data and at the point where
there's public examples of someone being
able to exploit an attack
that equation is flipped it's no longer
better for users and better for
people to have a secret going you know a
secret vulnerability that they don't
know how to defend against if someone
else knows how to attack
and so that kind of forced our hand into
talking about the issue a little bit
earlier than we were originally planning
to
but you guys were pretty close to
getting out there anyways with this
information
so close i think i think the two
important things to be aware of there
that it really was
only a matter of days before the
original disclosure date and then the
other thing
uh calling back to some of matt's other
comments the
things that people were seeing that were
leading them to ask these questions
and start kind of probing these areas
were
those supply chain level mitigations
right they'd seen linux deploying
patches for meltdown they'd seen
microsoft deploying patches for meltdown
apple deployed patches from up down
this this kind of coordinated
improvement
doesn't happen by accident so that kind
of was immediately setting off people's
alarm bells that that something was
going on but also
the fact that all of those vendors had
those the time to develop those patches
was why the disclosure was delayed so
that
even though people were seeing those
things happen in the supply chain
they had happened so that when uh
disclosure
did occur even though it's actually a
few days early there were protections
available
and in many cases deployed to all of the
major computing platforms
that users depended on um well i think
we're slightly running out of time here
uh but before we wrap up is there
anything that you want to make sure you
mentioned maybe
something we haven't covered or if
there's extra information that maybe
people should go look at or listen to or
watch
that that we haven't managed to cover so
far sure i i think
uh generally speaking this was a really
good example of a lot of people in the
industry coming together to look at a
really tough problem
and i expect that really in many ways
we may have opened pandora's box here
there are going to be
new ways to attack these hardware
features people are really going to
start looking
at other parts of the cpu and how we can
how they can potentially be exported in
a similar fashion
and while that obviously potentially
presents a rich new vein of exploits for
malicious users i'm really encouraged by
the fact that
as an industry we seem to be moving in a
good direction
to be able to prevent them and protect
users
the best of our ability yeah i don't
think i really have too much to add on
top of what paul said i think there's a
lot of
research in this area that's going to go
forward into the future and i think
you know like it or not the next 10
years of
the industry is still going to be a
constant cycle of
finding out new and interesting things
that are unexpected about our software
and then rolling out ways to make them
behave the way we originally thought
they would behave
and i think that's i mean that's if
that's not
an integral part of the computer
industry at this point i don't know what
is well great thank you both very much
for joining us and sharing
this information we appreciate it and
that's all we got
thank you thanks guys yeah thank you
have a good one thanks
all right thanks matt and paul we
appreciate that and
mark i think that's going to be it for
today's episode because we're keeping it
a special episode we'll definitely do
our questions and cool things for the
next one yeah see you on wednesday then
see you then
you